The goal of encryption is to transform
a plaintext into an intelligible form.
That is, given that the attacker
can obtain the ciphertext,
we don't want the attacker to be
able to learn about the plaintext.
In order to accomplish this,
we apply two principles.
The first is called confusion,
it is a way to obscure the relationship
between a key and a ciphertext.
That is, although the attacker
can obtain the ciphertext,
the attacker will not be
able to find out the key.
This is typically achieved
with substitution.
For example, in the generalized
substitution ciphers that we
have discussed, each letter can
be mapped to any other letter.
Confusion or
substitution alone is not sufficient.
For example, even when a letter can be
mapped to any other letter, the attacker
can use statistical analysis of data
frequencies to break the scheme.
Therefore, the second
principle is diffusion.
This means that the influence of one
plaintext bit is spread over many
bits in a ciphertext and
the goal is to hide the statistical
properties of the plaintext.
For example, in stead of mapping
an English letter to another
English letter, we can map a letter
to parts of many a bit letters.
And if you do that, then the frequency
distribution of English letters will not
be very useful in cryptanalysis.
We can achieve diffusion
with permutations.
Further, we need this combination to
effect every bit of the ciphertext.
Therefore, typically,
a block cipher has multiple rounds
where each round combines
substitution and permutation.
That is, the first round affects some
parts of the ciphertext and the next
round further propagates these effects
into other parts of the ciphertext.
Eventually, all bits of
ciphertext are affected.